-A lot of people like the
matter-of-fact way
that you have been giving
your daily press conferences
One part that people seem
to appreciate
is the PowerPoint slide.
I can tell you, personally
I'm a big fan of the slide
that it tells us what day it is.
I find it informative
and I like that
it cannot be questioned.
Are you surprised, having
a long career in politics,
that people have finally
come around
to appreciating the value
of PowerPoint?
-Yes. I think
it's a little retro.
I have been mocked for man
years for my PowerPoints.
That it's dated.
It's boring.
But I always ascribe
to the theory
some people process
information by hearing it.
Some people need to see it
A PowerPoint, you get both
You get people
who are visually oriented
and they can watch
the PowerPoint
and people who wanna
hear it can hear it.
But I think what's worked is
people want the facts, you know.
This is a frightening situation.
It's probably
the first time government
has really been relevant
in a generation
or two generations,
when you think about it.
And, now, everything has
such spin and politics to it
that you get to a situatio
like this and they wanna say
"Well, just tell me
the facts, first, right?
I'm not that interested
in your opinion.
Give me the facts,
so I have a basis
to evaluate your opinion."
And nobody was doing that.
And I first lay out the fact
when I'm gonna give my opinion
I say, you know,
"Warning -- opinion.
But here are the facts."
And I think that's essential
for people to get grounded
with where they are.
This is about you and your
life and your family.
You want the facts
to make your own decision.
From my point of view,
you know,
government can't really
do any of the things
we're trying to do right now
Government doesn't
have the power
to make people stay at home.
The only way it works is
if people
understand the information
and then accept it
and choose to follow it, right
So, I say, "Here are the facts
and my opinion is, therefore
we should stay at home,
close businesses,
close schools, wear a mask."
And they have done it,
the compliance is high,
because they heard the facts
and they accepted it.
But, if they didn't
have the facts,
they could've just told me
to pound sand, you know,
or whatever the equivalent is.
-You don't strike me as someon
who's coy with your opinions
I'm wondering, when you're
actually out right now,
practicing social distancing
of course,
do you share your opinion,
if you see someone
who is not wearing a mask,
not practicing
a safe social distance?
-Yeah, well, this is
New York, you know.
We all have an opinion
and we all want to share it,
at different decibel levels.
Yes, I feel the mask,
for example,
I feel strongly about masks.
I think it's disrespectful
for people not to wear a mask.
You see all these
TV commercials now --
"We applaud our doctors
our nurses, our heroes."
Okay.
Then wear a mask, right?
Then don't infect anyone else.
Then make their life
easier, right?
"Well, I can do whatever I
want myself."
Yes. God bless you.
You're an individual.
This is America.
But you don't have a right
to infect me.
You don't have a right
to infect my daughter.
So, wear a mask.
And it's not that big a deal
You can get a cool-lookin' mask.
You can get a fashionable mask
So, something like that, yes
I think it's just gratuitous
and disrespectful
not to wear a mask
in this situation.
It's also so irresponsible
you know.
Yeah, it's annoying.
-If you've ever had to tel
someone on the street
to put the mask on
and you're wearing a mask,
how quickly do they recogniz
that they're talking
to the governor,
or do you think they even do
-No, I think they do
because my mask
always has a large bulge
in it, Seth,
because I can't really get one
that handles my nose,
so you can tell,
even with the mask,
who you're talking to.
-Right.
Well, we'll leave it at that
that if you see someone
with a large, bulging mask
telling you to put one on,
-[ Laughing ]
-you might be talking
[ Laughing ] to the governor
Thanks so much
for making the time for us
We look forward to more update
and we're certainly --
Cause for optimism,
would you say?
-Yeah. I think, if we're smart
we're over the worst of it
We did what we had to do,
which was change the curve
flatten the curve.
We did that.
We just now have to make sur
we're smart enough to keep it up
and we don't go backwards,
and that's what this whole
Dr. Fauci
and don't open too soon
and don't allow the warm weather
to change your behavior,
that's what we have to watch
But we did what we needed to do.
We just have to be disciplined
and stay with it.
-Alright, well, thank you
so much for making time for us
and we will see you soon.
Governor Andrew Cuomo, everyone.
-Thanks.
Thanks for having me, Seth